so lastly compare and contrast query by
example with structured query language
can we put it all together remember
compare means to ask the things that are
the same contrast means that things are
different right so let's go SQL
comparing contrast let's do comparing
first what things are similar between
these two good yep they both obviously
are about databases right and it's about
getting data out of the databases okay
that's the that is by the way that's the
primary similarity computer okay other
similarities between say that again yep
okay so they still are let's be a little
more specific they still require user
initiated requests okay so it's not an
automatic process okay let me give you
another one both of them are really
actually like at the most fundamental
level
they're searching in just the same way
right is the same search algorithm
underneath both right it's just the QBE
kind of disguises a little bit it makes
it look a little neater okay
but SQL still there in the background
doing its thing okay what about the
difference is now differences
okay good so I think I said this was SQL
whoa yep so we've got here typed
commands okay so you've got to do you
rotate select and from and where and
order by go do all those things okay
whereas what you've got over here is
more like filling out a form
okay any other differences think back to
the user development sort of those
countries what do you mean by that
yeah okay so I guess the way the way
that I'd say that is SQL gives you more
direct access okay
whereas as we mentioned before you've
got abstract processes here right so
you're not in you're not directly
interacting with the database you sort
of another step back okay I think it's a
pretty good set